bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7 8
nouvelle édition pour faire le point sur
l'actualité du département chaque soir
en direct entre 18 et 19h en plateau
avec nous pour débuter cette édition
Jean-Philippe Mallet député PS de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines pour
évoquer sa rentrée parlementaire
également Clément Gadea entraîneur de
tennis de table à Élancourt il supervise
Florence Sirault Gossio qui est à
Londres pour les Jeux Paralympique
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir et nous
recevrons également dans un instant tout
à l'heure va nous rejoindre Jean-Michel
Coignard le directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale pour
parler de ces premiers jours d'école
Jean-Philippe Mallet déjà un mot sur
cette rentrée parlementaire elle a été
avancée normalement elle était prévue le
24 septembre ce sera le 11 ça veut dire
qu'il y a urgence oui bien sûr vous
l'avez bien compris il y a urgence sur
sur les questions de l'emploi en sorte
que effectivement la session
parlementaire va débuter mardi prochain
le 11 septembre les premiers dossiers
justement projets de loi portant sur la
création des 150 000 emplois d'avenir
sur les logements sociaux également
création de 150 000 voilà changement est
venu sur la table du Conseil des
ministres hier il y aura dans un
deuxième temps le contrat de génération
ensuite un petit peu plus tard la
sécurisation des parcours et puis à la
fin du mois il y aura évidemment le
projet de budget pour 2013 et puis le
traité le traité européen nous ferons le
point justement sur ces différentes
réformes avec vous ce sera d'ailleurs
votre première rentrée parlementaire
puisque je le rappelle Benoît Hamon été
élu dans cette onzième circonscription
vous étiez sans suppléant vous prenez sa
place donc à l'Assemblée puisqu'il est
resté au gouvernement bonsoir également
Alice on va parler d'économie avec vous
la chronique de l'écho comme tout les
jeudis sera question d'économie et du
chômage les mauvais chiffres du chômage
dans les Yvelines également et oui bien
sûr on va s'intéresser au chiffre du
chômage puisque fin juillet la barre des
3 millions de demandeurs d'emploi a été
dépassés en France les Yvelines ne sont
pas épargnés puisque le chômage a
augmenté de 1,2 % en un mois soit une
hausse de 7,1% en un an la page Eco
d'ici il y a une demi-heure merci Alice
et à tout à l'heure on passe donc pour
l'instant notre fée du jour c'est la
colère des buralistes aujourd'hui les
buralistes se sont fait entendre
et pour comprendre cette colère un
chiffre qui va apparaître à l'écran plus
0,40,40 centimes c'est là où ce minimum
du prix du tabac envisagé dans les
prochaines semaines par le gouvernement
les buralistes se sont fait entendre
aujourd'hui plusieurs opérations coup de
poing dans leur ligne de mire le
gouvernement mais aussi Bruxelles qui
souhaitent mettre en vente des paquets
neutres et même les faire disparaître
des étals les précisions de Maxime Le
Maine depuis la ville de Maurepas ou un
buraliste justement qui représente le
syndicat départemental était mobilisé
drap blanc sur les étalages de
cigarettes ce matin dans ce bar de
Maurepas un signe de protestation contre
un projet de loi européen visant à
obliger l'industrie du tabac
commercialisé des paquets neutres sans
marque sans logo mais avec des images
choc plus grandes parallèlement à cette
mesure le gouvernement annoncé une
nouvelle hausse de 6% du prix du tabac
pour Jean-François Vigouroux patron de
l'établissement sans métro on nous fait
passer pour des marchands de morts c'est
l'humiliation pour les fumeurs je pense
qu'il y a autre chose à faire que de
nous empêcher de travailler et pour nous
la première des premiers des problèmes
pour les buralistes c'est la contrebande
il faut savoir que elle représente plus
de 20% de du marché donc c'est à dire
que quand on vend quatre paquets il y a
un paquet qui est vendu à l'extérieur du
réseau Jean-François Vigouroux reconnaît
qu'il y a un véritable problème de santé
publique en France mais selon lui et la
dizaine de buralistes yvelinois en
colère rassemblés ce matin augmenter les
prix et changer le format des paquets
est une fausse solution
Antonio Gomes est également buraliste à
Maurepas à chaque nouvelle hausse du
prix du tabac il perd des clients si les
choses continuent dans ce sens il se
verra dans l'obligation de diversifier
son activité où je vais faire je vais
essayer de faire restauration mais il y
a des inconvénients aussi ou
je sais pas si on peut vendre d'autres
articles
je me suis pas encore bien posé la
question mais bon il va falloir trouver
une solution en tout cas malgré les
campagnes publicitaires l'interdiction
de fumer dans les lieux publics ou
encore la hausse du prix des cigarettes
une étude de l'INPES rapporte que la
part de fumeurs réguliers âgée de 15 à
75 ans a augmenté de deux points entre
2005 et 2010 rappelons que le tabac est
le principal facteur de risque du cancer
et comme nous avons sur ce plateau un
député Jean-Philippe Mallet député de la
majorité socialiste justement c'est
cette augmentation du tabac est justifié
est-elle justifiée et puis que
pensez-vous des mesures qui sont prévues
par Bruxelles justement de ces tabac
c'est paquets de tabac masqué oui moi je
vous savez je ne suis pas
favorable à ces mesures que ce soit sur
ce dossier pardon ou d'autres
tropiques quoi imposé par Bruxelles ceci
dit votre journaliste conclut le
reportage par par ce constat le tabac la
consommation de tabac et le principal
facteur de cancer quoi de mort par
cancer en France il faut augmenter le
prix du paquet ce ne sont pas les
buralistes qui sont visés c'est
effectivement la consommation ils sont
victimes alors effectivement il y a des
solutions et un des buralistes en parler
de diversification effectivement des
activités mais je tiens à dire que ce ne
sont pas eux qui sont qui sont visés
évidemment ils ont ils en souffrent et
faire entraînement des pédagogies à
faire en tout cas du gouvernement des
élus pour expliquer qui est tout à fait
reconvertir et évolué en tout cas à la
disposition des buralistes pour pour les
rencontrer et les écouter j'imagine
qu'ils auront envie de vous rencontrer
justement dans les prochains mois
puisque les discussions vont poursuivons
se poursuivre justement alors ce plan
petit tabac peut-il être efficace c'est
en tout cas la question que se pose les
consommateurs nous sommes allés à votre
rencontre pour recueillir vos avis et
puis on se retrouve donc juste après
avec nos invités il sera notamment à
question de sport des Jeux paralympiques
on fera un point sur une athlète 5
continents ce qui est engagé là-bas
augmenter les prix des paquets vu que
ceux qui auront les moyens auront
toujours l'occasion d'acheter bon ce
qu'on fait les moyens après bon ce sera
une autre histoire oui je pense que ce
serait bien tout simplement dans pour la
santé des gens non non parce que toute
façon un peu tabac ça servira rien ça
n'empêche pas de fumer il y a toujours
la tentation et puis il est fumeurs
fumeront toujours quoi que ce soit le
prix ou qu'est-ce qui se passe mis en
place il y aura toujours des fumeurs moi
je dirais non parce que façon même s'ils
augmentent les prix les fumeurs ils vont
toujours acheter donc
moi je dirais plus que c'est pour les
caisses de l'État qu'ils augmentent les
prix voilà quoi simplement non non
pourquoi et ben parce que il y a toute
la contrebande qui arrive et ça c'est du
marché parallèle donc nous les fumeurs
on sait ce qu'on veut fumer exactement
donc restons en France